vibranium modified genes and enemies
unexpected return and a new challenge to
the throne if you walked away from
wakanda forever with questions we've got
the answers
[Music]
the impact of Chadwick boseman's 2020
death is far from the very beginning of
wakanda forever the first scene even
before the traditional Marvel logo
Montage shows shuri trying desperately
to synthesize a cure for her brother's
illness the audience doesn't get much
explanation for what actually happened
to t'challa and the later news broadcast
describes his disease as being
mysterious the main action of the film
takes place a year after t'challa's
death itself occurring roughly five
years after the Thanos Infinity War snap
this is clear because when Queen ramonda
contacts Nakia in Haiti she's been gone
from wakanda for six years this is to
say it's possible that t'challa's
mysterious illness had something to do
with being brought back in the Avengers
endgame blib given the timing however
the film isn't really interested in
making such connections instead it
treats t'challa's passing as a mirror of
Bozeman's own blurring the lines between
real world and in Universe morning in a
powerful deeply affecting way like his
black panther character Bozeman died
from an illness that he chose to keep
secret from The World At Large
shocking overnight news that the actor
who was just 43 years old died of colon
cancer speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter in 2020 Bozeman's agent Michael
Green said that he intentionally kept
his colon cancer and treatments private
because he quote did not want to have
people fuss over him later in wakanda
Forever Sherry mentions that her brother
suffered in silence for a long time
a year after the death of t'challa
wakanda forever jumps to a meeting of
international leaders some of us less
admirable political powers are
frustrated with their lack of access to
wakanda's vibranium reserves and
advanced technology Queen ramonda enters
and delivers a cutting speech about how
most Nations can't be trusted intricate
with a scene of an undesignated Strike
Team infiltrating a wakandan facility
and getting absolutely wrecked by the
Dora milaje Okoye then burst into the
meeting with a captured Strike Team in
tow depositing them in front of the
French representative the implication
here seems to be that the strike team
was French military sent to a wakandan
Outpost outside of wakanda to steal
vibranium however the exact details
aren't specified remonda says that any
further efforts to steal vibranium will
be seen as acts of War but it honestly
feels a little strange that a single
coordinated attack isn't enough to push
her to more drastic measures one of the
recurring themes in the Black Panther
sequel is a relationship between
Vengeance and well-being in the
community
umbaku later tells shuri that her mother
wouldn't have wanted her to drag wakanda
into war to avenge her death which makes
this early moment of ramonda showing
Mercy much more significant she always
considers that told her actions could
take on her people wishes something sure
he must learn to do as well Italia
carneil revealed themselves in Striking
fashion at the beginning of black
panther wakanda forever the film jumps
to a secret U.S deep sea mining
operation in the middle of the ocean
which is using new technology to search
for vibranium however when a pair of
divers goes down to investigate a
potential find the whole mining rig is
ambushed by a squad of talocaniel led by
Neymar one thing in this sequence never
fully explained is the hypnotic tune
used by the talukanil to lure soldiers
into the sea once the music starts the
Guard Station on the platform start
dropping into the ocean one by one
seemingly robbed of their free will it
is subsequently explained that Sonic
communication is integral to the culture
and structure of talocon which makes
sense given how common echo location is
in aquatic animals the dangerous Sonic
attack that lures these soldiers to
their watery Mass grave is never
explicitly explained but it has roots in
the common mythology of siren songs
supposedly used by mermaids to attract
prey
[Music]
lastly there's an interesting detail
included right before the talukanil
attack while underwater one of the
divers sees a massive red phantom
jellyfish presumably the creature was
summoned by Namor to serve as a
destruction but its inclusion is
particularly interesting given that may
more is later compared to a jellyfish by
shuri his method of extracting oxygen
from water is quite similar and the
appearance of the jellyfish can
therefore be read as a subtle
foreshadowing
viewers first see Neymar when he attacks
the ocean mining platform but don't
formally meet him until the later scene
where he introduces himself to shuri and
queen mamonda the two are having a quiet
moment on the bank of a river discussing
their grieving for t'challa when Neymar
Spooks some elephants and emerges from
beneath the water levitating on his
ankle Wings the queen is shocked that he
was able to get past wakanda's defenses
presumably just by swimming up River the
whole way from the sea what's harder to
explain is how he manages to get the
vibranium detector a massive machine
onto the shore next to them unnoticed
clearly Neymar didn't come at River
alone he must have had a crew in tow
likely the same later seen attacking
shuri Okoye and Riri nevertheless the
only way the talukanil could have
possibly removed the machine from the
water so quickly and quietly as with
immense strength and superb stealth
Trace has show off numerous times later
in the film The depositing of the
machine is essentially an intimidation
tactic showing the queen and princess
just how easily Neymar and his followers
could sneak into wakanda whenever they
choose one of the great new additions to
the MCU in Black Panther wakanda forever
is Riri Williams AKA ironheart
a teenage genius who builds a vibranium
locator for a school project Riri
becomes a target of both Neymar and the
United States government when shuri and
okorier intervene to help her they all
wind up at a massive Warehouse which
essentially functions as riri's lab how
does she manage to afford all of her
gear let alone the rent for this
Warehouse well for one Riri is clearly a
hustler introductory scene shows her
getting paid for helping other MIT
students with their homework she later
says that she's been building things
since she was three years old so it's
not hard to imagine her affording
something like a secret lab on the
merits of her talents and drive of
course the most interesting feature of
the warehouse is a DIY Iron Man or
rather ironheart's suit that Riri say
she's been working on for years she
mentions in passing that there's a whole
sect of the internet complete with
YouTube videos dedicated to the kind of
garage build super suit that she's
managed to craft given how many years
it's been since Tony Stark first took
flight it makes total sense that such an
indie scene would exist
after an action-packed escaped from the
FBI shuri Okoye and Riri are targeted by
a squad of tala canal with the other two
women out cold okay does her best to
fight the attackers off and she makes
short work of most of them delivering a
few seemingly fatal blows however her
opponents aren't quite as devastated as
they seem the warrior atuma is the only
one left standing at a point but that's
all it takes from him is another Call to
Arms and the other telecon they'll rise
up again the way they stand up makes it
look like something Supernatural is
happening but this is never confirmed in
reality it's probably just a mark of how
much stronger talo Carnel are than
regular humans even when fighting on
land of course it helps that they're all
decked out in vibranium gear though that
shouldn't be enough to save you from a
spear through the belly after
volunteering to travel to talukan with
Riri shuri gets a chance to properly get
to know Neymar his story augmented by a
series of flashbacks is fascinating in
past because of how closely it mirrors
wakanda's own Neymar's people a
Mesoamerican group from the UK Sam
Peninsula were decimated by smallpox and
other dangers brought by Spanish
Invaders In the late 16th century
prayers to one of their gods LED them to
a strange plant that when Ethan brought
about a powerful transformation the
people who ate it saw their skin turn
blue and felt their lungs turned to
gills forcing them into the water to
survive Neymar himself was born a mutant
after his mother ingested the strange
plants while pregnant with him note that
this term does not overtly connect to
the X-Men's story as a result he was
born with the wings on his ankles and
pointed ears as well as the ability to
breathe both underwater and in the air
he's also implied to be immortal at the
very least he can live a very long time
there are a number of fascinating
details here quickly glossed over well
different from the heart-shaped herb the
plant found by the Tallow car nil is
also the product of a vibranium-rich
soil according to shuri and just like
how the prior to the wakanda goddess bus
led to the discovery of vibranium so too
did a deity help the Tallow Canal reach
salvation why the plant transformed
Neymar's people in such a specific way
is unclear but it hints at an even
larger mythology around vibranium after
being filled in on Neymar's origin story
shuri has taken on a tour of talocon
viewers don't get to spend much time in
the gorgeous underwater city but there
are a lot of interesting details that
help add Dimension and context for
Neymar's people and their society at the
center of the city is a massive
pyramid-like Temple which surely quickly
recognizes as being made of vibranium
out of this Temple emerges a ball of
light that illuminates the entire city
many more saves with pride from the
bottom of the ocean I brought the sun to
my people what exactly is this strange
device how does it work what is its
purpose such questions on given much
explanation but a look at wakanda's own
vibranium-based technology offers ideas
while vibranium is most famous in its
solidified metal form it is also a
powerful energy source wakanda's ships
and advanced technology all take their
power from vibranium with that in mind
it's not hard to Envision someone like
Neymar being able to create a synthetic
Sun utilizing the same kind of
Technology as vibranium has very few
known limitations in MCU Cannon it's
also worth noting that the local talu
Carnel don't appear blue and underwater
Namor is never blue but as Warriors take
on a blue hue when fighting above the
surface this shift may be due to some
unexplained byproduct of their
transformation for the first half of
wakanda forever it looks like War might
not break out between the wakandans and
natalo Carnell however or hopes of a
peaceful resolution to their disputes
are destroyed when the Kia kills the two
guards holding Riri and shuri Namor
wastes no time Gathering his forces and
infiltrating wakanda the manner with
which he attacks however is clouded
seemingly out of nowhere the streets of
the capital city begin to flood entire
streets and districts are submerged in
the Deluge almost instantaneously and
salukan warriors follow in the Wake
where is all this water coming from well
fortunately for Namor the city is built
along some major waterways it seems that
the talukanil breaks some barriers at
the start of their attack allowing the
flooding to begin and they amplify that
flooding with an arsenal of Their Own
water bombs Glimpse in several scenes
throughout the film the flooding is
necessary so that the talocaniel can
fight at full strength it's an easy way
to destabilize their foes of course the
main impact of Neymar's invasion is the
death of Queen mamonda the entirety of
the attack occurs because wakanda under
her leadership refuses to end an
innocent life after the throne room is
flooded viewers see ramonda make a
choice she could have escaped and left
Riri to die but then what would have
been the point instead she chooses to
save Riri someone with whom she is
barely acquainted knowing full well she
may die for it but that's just a kind of
queen momonda has always been
I wouldn't stand a chance
we'll go after her mother dies Sherry
plunges even more deeply into grief and
rage her earlier claims that she wants
to burn the whole world begin to feel
powerfully real and it becomes clear
that wakanda forever is her story more
so than anyone else in the interests of
Vengeance she resumes her work trying to
synthesize a new heart-shaped herb this
time using a combination of her
brother's DNA and the vibranium Rich
fibers in the bracelet name or gave her
the idea here essentially is that with
enough understanding of how vibranium
works the effect it has on plant life
and the effect the herb has on the human
body shuri is able to replicate the
effect and that's exactly what she
manages to do with some help from Riri
could Suri have recreated the
heart-shaped her without Neymar's gift
had she been given the motivation before
it's possible the film leaves ambiguous
how much of shuri's success is due to
new information and how much is the
result of the fire already lit within
her when Sherry ingests are hard-shaped
herb Nakia asked that her mother meet
her on the ancestral plane it would make
sense for Queen momonda to be the one
waiting for her as tachala was met by
their father when he first journeyed
there but the person waiting for shuri
isn't exactly the one she expects to
find stand up you are a King instead of
her mother it's Eric killmonger who
greets her seated on a wakandan throne
surrounded by Flames he encourages shuri
to embrace the raid within her to take
all the power she can and strike back
against the world that has hurt her so
much apparently as this rage that brings
her to killmonger in the first place
sure you miss that she never really
believed the ancestral plane was real
before and that she only ingested the
her because she wanted enough strength
to kill Neymar the implication is that
the herb can tell a person's intention
and adjust their experience accordingly
shuri certainly misses her mother but
she likely knows what embaku tells her
later is true that remonda wouldn't want
her to go to war even for her own sake
so instead shuri subconsciously he seeks
an ancestor who'd be more supportive of
her bid for Revenge killmonger fits that
Bell quite nicely
when shuri goes into a final battle
against Neymar at the end of wakanda
forever she doesn't do it alone
obviously embaku the Dora milaje and
some other wakandan Warriors join her
mission to kill Neymar but she has three
particularly strong allies thanks to
some new super suits Riri emerges in a
new and improved ironheart suit under
Korea and daneka get their Dora skills
maxed out with some new Midnight Angel
suits of course einhardt is a familiar
character for fans of the comics and the
star of her own MCU series after wakanda
forever but the Midnight's angels are
also pulled from the comics in the
comics are the most elite members of the
Dora melange but they don't get the cool
blue super sou makes for them in the
movie all three of these suits seem to
be hybrids of the old black panther suit
Tony Stark's later Iron Man models and
show his own personal Innovations the
end result is quite impressive at the
talocaniel quickly find out after a
tense action-packed battle shuri has the
opportunity to kill Neymar she wants to
avenge her mother but is bigger than
that she has all her rage at the world
into a hatred of Neymar but when she has
the blade at his neck she just can't go
through with her she realizes all the
ways in which wakanda and talukan are
the same she sees herself in namor's
people and of course she gets a soft
hand on her shoulder from her mother who
appears to tell her not to go through
with her revenge it's not entirely clear
whether this is truly remondo Channel
order through the power of the
heart-shaped herb or if it's simply a
manifestation of shuri's inner turmoil
but at the same time she sees her mother
Neymar sees his it's possible that this
is a truly mystical moment the effects
of vibranium modified genes striking
both characters at once and connecting
them to their deceased parents
regardless a forge a piece out of it
albeit one that maymore makes with other
intentions in mind as he reveals to
namora at the end of the movie he
believes the rest of the world will come
for wakanda eventually when they do
shuri may be desperate enough to agree
to Neymar's plans for all-out war
whether does settled from wakanda's
brief war with talocon Sherry goes on a
little trip to see Nakia in Haiti though
wakandan gathering in celebration of the
New Black Panther gets a record scratch
moments when embaku not shuri descends
from a ship and announces that the
princess won't be joining them he then
announces his desire to make a bid for
the throne something he did
unsuccessfully in the first black
panther before being defeated and later
embraced by t'challa
sin Cuts away before the audience can
see how it will play out leaving things
a bit confusing there was dialogue after
Amanda's death where the elders mention
their need to choose a new leader even
after shuri gains her powers and dons
the Black Panther suit she's referred to
as Princess not queen of course if a
condom Throne is always up for grabs to
those willing to fight for it but sure
he isn't even present when embaku makes
his bed maybe she has no desire to be
queen of wakanda or perhaps she's just
happy being the Black Panther protector
of her people and all around science
wears it's possible that some Baku is
making a power play in her absence but
given his loyalty throughout the film
that seems unlikely MCU fans will have
to wait for Black Panther's MCU return
to see how this whole situation plays
out but for now it's clear sure he is
taking some time alone to process and
heal as her mother encouraged black
panther wakanda forever doesn't have a
traditional MCU post-credits sequence
but there is a scene worth sticking
around for after the first round of
credits roll as she watches her funeral
clothes burn on the beach in Haiti
surely meets an unexpected stranger the
son of her late brother and the Kia who
Bears his father's name how does this
secret child exist presumably he was
conceived surely before the infinity War
snap as Nakia was present in wakanda up
until tachala was taken by Thanos that
would have allowed Nakia to leave for
Haiti before anyone would have noticed
that she was pregnant it also would have
meant that t'challa wouldn't have met
his son until he was four or five after
the late King returned to life in the
blip even after that he and Nakia
decided to keep their child a secret so
that he might grow up having a normal
childhood Nakia tells shuri that
t'challa prepared her and their son for
his death and that remondo got to meet
the boy presumably this is what raimonda
wanted to tell shuri about her brother
on the night they met Neymar after an
entire movie about the effects of grief
meeting the young t'challa is a welcomed
spark of hope he's a reminder that
family never really dies and that the
future can once again be bright
[Music]